-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#ThatHappened tweets
from you guys.
Remember, Higgins, this is
"That happened."
This is one from @klaracee91
She said "Got a speeding ticke
and sped away
when the cop handed it to me
because I was so mad.
He pulled me over again
and gave me another ticket."
There you go. That's --
-That happened.
This one's from @Cutebricks.
She says, "Once my boyfriend
told me he wanted to have
a romantic walk on the beach
He actually took me
to see a dead whale
he had heard about on the news."
[ Laughter ]
-[ Imitates explosion ]
It blew up.
-You want to see a dead whale?
♪♪ When the night ♪♪
♪♪ Has gone ♪♪
"Stand By Me 2."
This one's from @MarkWinterton
He says, "In kindergarten
I put on my coat in the mornin
and forgot that I wasn't wearing
a shirt until I got to school.
What's up?
-What's up?
-What's going on, teach?
What's happening?
That child was Flea
from Red Hot Chili Peppers
-Are you serious?
Shirtless to this day.
Vladimir Putin.
-This one is @LisaMurray 89.
She says, "I waited behind
a group of mannequins
for 20 minutes in the stor
thinking it was the line."
It's like --
Got to stop texting.
-This cashier is the worst
[ Coughing ]
-This one is from @Whappy.
-Huh, hey, what? Huappy?
-Whappy.
-Whappy. W-H?
-Yeah.
-Whappy.
-Wha-- Not Whacky.
-Not whacky, but whappy.
-No. Whappy.
-Whappy.
[ Imitates whip cracking ]
That happened.
[ Laughter ]
-Whappy...
[ Imitates whip cracking ]
-That happened.
-Could we --
Could we get a whip sound, Fred?
Can you work on just finding
a whip sound,
and then, I'll say,
"That -- That happened"
after we do it?
Whappy52.
-[ Imitates whip cracking
[ Metal clangs ]
That happened.
-Alright. @Whappy52 --
-It's a living.
[ Whip cracking ]
-Alright. Stop.
Fred, Fred, Fred. Fred.
Somebody make sure --
Fred. Is he alright?
Somebody make sure Fred's okay
[ Laughter ]
Make sure that Fred,
our sound guy, is okay.
That sounds like he was get-
That sounded a little --
sounded serious.
Thank you, Fred.
-Yikes.
-Everyone was out late
watching the game last night
-That happened.
[ Whip cracking ]
-No, stop. Fred.
Stop, stop.
It's just at this point
a disaster.
[ Laughter ]
The whole night is a disaster.
-That happened.
Alright, she says, "My dog
pooped on the neighbor's lawn.
I ran home to get a bag
and returned to find
my neighbors blaming each other.
I just walked away."
I was, like...
You guys figure this out.
It's definitely someone.
-That's not from a dog.
-This one is from @DNA6971
He says, "I got scared by th
reflection of my own eyeball
while peeking
through the blinds."
It's like...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from @joshuaqdaily.
He says, "At a red light,
I saw a guy get out of his car
and grab a bag of taco seasoning
from his windshield."
[ Laughter ]
I guess he's got like a --
like a chip clip? Yeah.
-What am I going to do
with this taco seasoning?
-That's where he keeps
his taco seasoning.
Yeah.
This one's from @bengalgirl68.
She says, "I was mad at my kid
so I punted the head off
the snowman we had just made
It was a solid block of ice.
Broke my foot."
Well, that -- that is karma.
-Yeah. That is.
-That is karma.
Punted off the head
of the snowman?
-With a roundhouse kick.
-What's wrong with people?
This one's from @Sweetiepiee
She says, "Got out of a taxi
and my skirt ripped open.
I leaned up against a wall
It was the window
of a restaurant."
There you are. Those are our
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags
-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
-And now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
"I Got Busted" tweets
from you guys.
Here it goes.
Some of our favorites.
-Favorite hashtags.
-This is some of
our favorite hashtags.
-Yeah. Favorite hashtags.
-This is up to this week.
This topic.
-On this specific topic?
-That is correct.
-Yes.
-This one's from @knr 106.
She says, "I got caught smokin
with my cousin.
When her brother asked
if we were smoking,
smoke came out of her mout
when she said 'No.'"
-Ohh.
[ Laughter ]
-She got busted.
-This one's from @twic1214
She says,
"I was Facebooking in church
and the usher passed by
and whispered
'You better be texting Jesus.'
[ Laughter ]
-Ohh.
-Really?
-Jesus will never unfriend you
-No. That's true.
[ Laughter ]
-This one's from @BesjanaSadiku.
She says,
"My mom walked in on me
standing in front of the mirro
flipping myself off
because I wanted to know
what it looked like."
-Bes has led a blessed life.
-What?
-I know what it looks like
-Yeah.
Yeah, unfortunately,
yeah, you do.
This one's from @rjdralle.
He says, "I got busted
yelling at myself
in an Arnold Schwarzenegge
voice
during a workout
because I was weak
and Arnold was the only on
who could motivate me."
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ As Arnold Schwarzenegger ] You
got to get on the treadmill now!
You got to do five minutes
at the eighth speed!
With the incline,
and the things.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
This one's from @jennilu76
She says, "I was on Facebook
at work and my boss walked in.
I slammed down what I though
was my laptop screen
but it was actually
my desktop monitor."
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-I wasn't doing anything.
Smoke.
This is from @Anicet01.
He says, "I lied and told
my Dad school was canceled
He said 'Let's go see a movie.
We got in the car and he
dropped me off at school."
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Yeah. That's the move, Dad.
-Yeah.
-Smart dad. That's the best.
-Yeah. Dad one, kid zero.
-Yeah. Let's go see a movie.
We'll have a good time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah
Go get in the car.
Yeah. Get out.
This one's from @bluedevil13
He says, "I was standing
in my neighbor's driveway
with my laptop stealing
his Wi-Fi when he came home.
It's like, "Oh, hey,
how you doing, Bob?"
"No. I wasn't doing anything."
This one's from @kellyintenn
She says, "As a kid,
my mom walked in on me
using the toilet backwards
while hand-drumming on the top
of the tank and singing."
-What?
-Sitting on the
toilet backwards.
Hand drumming on the sink?
-I guess it's on the tank.
-On the back of the tank?
-The tank.
Has anyone ever done that?
You've done that, sir?
What is wrong with you?
Just --
Just play a little tunes?
-Yeah, a little tune.
-Yeah, just jamming out there?
Yeah. And -- And it's fun?
-Oh, absolutely.
-Yeah. Oh, yeah.
You want me to try it tonight?
-You try it.
-Yeah. I'm -- No.
But thank you.
-You did that -- You did tha
in your she shed, right?
-My sh--
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @rhinorhinoo
She says, "A few weeks ago
my boss walked past my offic
just as I stuck my face
into a pile of dry cereal
to eat it like an animal."
[ Laughter ]
-What is going on?
-I don't know.
People are great, man.
Oh, this one's great.
This one comes with a picture.
-Oh, good.
-It's from @legallybecky.
She says,
"I drew eyebrows on my dog
They wouldn't come off
for a week."
Look at this. Hey.
-Yeah.
-There you have it. Those ar
the "Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out more of our
favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags
-♪♪ Hashtags ♪♪
-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#MyWeirdRoommate stories
from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one
is from @chrislilli.
He says, "I used to live
with a guy who would put ketchup
straight onto
our glass coffee table
to dip french fries in so he
could avoid cleaning a dish.
[ Audience groans ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Wow.
This one is from @MelLynn.
She says, "My roommate used to
knock on my bedroom door
in the middle of the night
and when I opened it,
she would say, 'Just checking.'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Okay.
Just terrified.
This one is from @wyyyyyit
-How many Y's?
-I think it's five Y's.
-W-h --
-W-y-y-y-y-y-i-t.
Wyyyyit.
-Wyyyyit.
-She says, "I wanted to get ou
of my apartment ASAP.
I saw an ad that said, 'Lookin
for a clean, quiet roommate.
I called the number.
It was my roommate."
[ Audience oohs ]
-Do you like piña coladas?
-[ Chuckles ]
-This next one's from @mahuls.
-Oh. Mahuls.
-She said --
You know Mahuls?
-Oh, Mahuls.
I love Mahuls.
[ Laughter ]
-No, that's not
the non-alcoholic beverage
that you drink.
-Oh, it's not?
-That is O'Doul's.
-Oh, that's O'Doul's.
Okay. I'm sorry.
I love O'Doul's.
-Mahuls is a non-alcoholic bar
-Non-alcoholic. [ Laughs ]
-The whole bar, non-alcoholic.
That's actually a play land.
It's a Gymboree.
-It's a Gymboree.
-It's a Gymboree for children.
Yeah, it's not even for adults
It's for children.
-The ball pit.
-It's a trampoline park.
-Yeah.
-I don't want to get into it
-Lot of lawsuits.
-[ Chuckles ]
Lot of lawsuits.
Because there's no license
-No, zero licensing.
And it's filthy.
-Actually, it is a bar.
It's a trampoline bar.
Anyways.
-Wait, it's a trampoline bar
-Anyways.
Yes, and there's a 6-foot pool
in there, as well.
You could trampoline
into the pool and drink.
It's awful.
They should close it down.
I've been saying,
"Please close Mahuls."
[ Laughter ]
I've always said that.
-Oh, you've always said that
You have that tattoo.
-This is -- I do.
I never get to see it.
-No, you can't see it.
-That's the only --
That's the problem.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-That's why I can't sleep
at night.
I can't see most of my tattoos
-You know what?
You should get a mirror
that's a double mirror
so you can see yourself
in the mirror backwards
so you can read your tattoos
You know what I'm saying?
-Yeah, I think.
But I'm a vampire,
so I can't even --
I don't have a reflection.
-Oh, I forgot.
I forgot.
-I don't have a reflection
You don't understand what --
-You're like Count Dracula Jr.
-[ Valley girl accent ]
You don't even understand
what my life is like.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You don't even understand
what my life is like!
Vampire with tattoos.
[ Normal voice ] Alright.
This is from @mahuls.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-She says, "My roommate woul
number her Kraft Singles
with a Sharpie so she'd know
if we took one."
Oh, God!
-Oh!
That's that.
Uh, I'm missing, uh,
Singles 7 through 10.
[ Laughter ]
-Did anybody eat those?
-Anyone hungry?
That's what I thought.
[ Laughter ]
Someone's eating my cheese
-We're going to Mahuls.
-We are going to Mahuls.
Meet me there if you want to
Well, that's my last name.
-Yeah.
-Oh, can you get us in?
No cover charge?
-For three Kraft Singles.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Chuckles ] Because
we're three crafty singles
And a little cheesy.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Alright.
Let's just go.
[ Mumbles ]
-Come on!
♪♪♪♪
Oh, his tattoo is acting up.
Walking across the stage..
and waving goodbye.
♪♪♪♪
Oh, my gosh!
You're taping
this whole episode.
-No, this is --
[ Laughter ]
Alexa, reco--
Alexa, record "The To--"
[ Thud ]
Uh, it wasn't Alexa.
It's felt tape.
Hey, this next one.
-Who is it from?
-This is from @paisleee.
-Oh, I love her.
[ Laughter ]
-She says, "There was a fire i
our building at 4:00 AM.
Smoke filled the halls,
but my roommate stopped
to curl her hair
in case a fireman saw her.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Alright.
Are you November?
[ Chuckles ]
[ Light laughter ]
Fireman calendar.
Okay.
-Thank you.
Fireman calendar reference
right?
Classic bit.
-November.
-Jimmy names
the fireman calendars.
[ Laughs ]
-You see, on calendars --
-Mr. November.
That's what I meant to say
This one's from @brianricci.
He says, "Every time my roommate
laughs at something on TV,
he looks at me to see if
I'm laughing, too."
It's like...
[ Laughs ]
No?
"I get it.
Do you get it?"
"No."
"I don't get it either."
-"Do you think it's funny?
-This last one
is from @mmmargolies.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-M.M.
-M.M. Margolies.
-M&M.
[ Light laughter ]
-[ As "Mahna Mahna" ]
Mah-nay mah-nem.
-♪♪ M.M. Margolies ♪♪
-Mah-nay mah-nem.
-♪♪ Margolies, too ♪♪
-♪♪ Margoo, Margolies ♪♪
♪♪ Margolies, Margolies ♪♪
♪♪ We're going to drink
at Mahuls ♪♪
-[ Scatting ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] This last one's
from @mmmargolies.
He says, "Once,
I couldn't figure out
why all my underwear
was missing.
I asked my roommate, and h
pulled down his pants and said
'Looking for these?'"
There you go.
Those are our
"Tonight Show" Hashtags.
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags